man i'm looking at this video they got
robots
in singapore in the park
and i don't know if you saw this thing
it's like a little electric dog it's
like a little
you know this little just a damn
uh it looks like a damn
future it looks like somebody took a
piece of the future and just
threw it in a park and it goes around
and tells people they're too close
together
and kind of videos it looks like it
video records also what is going on in
the park
uh it lets people know if they're in a
group
uh that that they need to be at least
one meter apart
i don't know if you saw this video or
not and it's just
it's an electronic it's a robot
and what i don't like about it first of
all it doesn't have a head so it looks
extremely
uh it has that whole futuristic look
you know every now and then on facebook
they'll come out with something real
futuristic that just
it kind of looks like it's just to scare
you like this is what it's gonna be like
but that's in singapore man okay
you let that loose in baltimore
somebody somebody first of all will have
that thing will have that
somebody will have that thing fighting a
pit bull in five minutes bro
you let that loose in baltimore
first of all somebody else would be
mating that thing
dude my buddy satchfield he'll mate that
thing with a damn australian shepherd
you have a couple little uh you know
you'll have a couple rt
r2d2s about
six weeks later however long it takes to
make a dog baby
but yeah i don't think this is the wave
of the future i think that this is
something that's kind of spooky about
science
because in some countries people aren't
people are going to listen to this
animal
to this robot animal but not here
dude if that thing comes close to
somebody they're going to pull out a uh
a weapon on it dude a couple crackheads
will
melt that thing's leg down and sell it
sell the copper out of that mf
so i i just think um you know you got a
unique deal here but i don't think that
this thing's something anybody needs to
be scared of not here
not in the u.s man
but it's definitely pretty fascinating a
boston dynamics robot named
spot was deployed in singapore to help
police
citizens during their nationwide
corvette lockdown spot roams around
public spaces and reminds people of
social distancing rules
and is equipped with cameras and
analytic tools to observe how many
people are in given space
breaches of singapore's strict lockdown
rules can result in fines or jail
yep and that's fine but let me just tell
you this you let that thing loose over
there on mcgee street where i grew up
bro somebody will steal that a little mf
for his leg bruh
and uh put that thing in
and and and use that thing somehow in a
damn toyota tercel
somebody somebody dude somebody melt
that little bastard down
and make a hubcap for a freaking 88
camry
in a heartbeat bro and that's factual
so in singapore yeah in baltimore
this little m this little m afro get
carjacked in a heartbeat good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one